hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now we
gotta get moving here because we got a
lot of stuff that we're going to be
doing today I'm going to build an alien
containment chamber to finally house
these eggs that I've been finding and
I'm going to do it in my secondary base
not the base I'm about to build down the
deep depths of hell I still have to get
more materials for that but before I go
on gathering materials again I am going
to do something that's actually useful
with my time and I'm gonna have some
friends well I heard about that
markiplier with friends what is this I
thought we were playing subnautica here
but no alas it is true I'm about to have
some real honest-to-goodness fish
friends that I promised I won't eat so
I'm going to put the lockers up here and
I'm going to read the names off the
lockers but before I do that I need to
actually do that so here we frickin go
okay so the first one goes to Alex see
fawn and people have been wondering how
to get names in the locker it's really
just I pull from the comments down below
so if you want your name to accompany me
down into the depths of Hell write a
comment give me some advice make me
laugh do whatever you want put a comment
down there so thanks guys but alex says
the jokey Kassar pod is buried beneath
the sand the pod entrance was literally
just below you and you didn't realize it
sorry that you didn't know this before
but now you do so thanks so much for
that advice I might go back there but
I'll go back there with bubble blood if
I do to save some time next up is
Samantha Nadler who said there's
something fishy about everything going
on but hey what are you going to do
about it I'm sure you can manage we
caught all do better don't you think
well I best be off
if you see a friend don't forget to wave
and also if you think of a better fish
button let me know so I'm officially
going to be banning Samantha's net ler
from my youtube comment section because
those are beyond wade level of puns and
the next one goes to Astro hard ammo who
I'm putting here is Astro hard could you
not cure the kaurav virus with people
and everyone knows that cold delicious
beef it solves all life problem chef
aatul Islaam said mark the sea dragon
leviathan egg is found in the disease
research facility and then you can put
it in the alien containment chamber
after a few days it will hatch with a
baby former of himself then you can mess
around with it but be careful it could
die when the creature is hatched it will
not attack you imagine to have your own
pet sea dragon Leviathan that is not
deadly can wait for it and you will have
to wait for it because I believe that's
in the dev building right now I'm
playing the normal game I may go to the
devil again and in fact I probably want
to do that I was a spear ah [ __ ] this
rocks ah yeah
I can't drive err I'm actually gonna
apparently I'm actually going to do a
flyby of jokey kiss Oregon so maybe just
maybe I can find that sea pod where that
is but then again maybe that's in the
dev build of the game and maybe I do
want to go over to the dev built you
know what I'm gonna do it I've gone back
and forth before I can do this again why
not hey Yolo or something am i right
what what oh no oh oh what damage you
can say anything about getting damaged
oh I was slamming my hole all over the
place how am I gonna be able to kill the
dragon okay but wow this or oh there
have been some updates oh oh my god this
is beautiful actually holy [ __ ]
they've updated just about goddamn
everything holy [ __ ] oh my god this is
amazing okay I gotta eat or something
because that's about to kill me but holy
[ __ ] not so pretty now oh I like the
unive it always what did I just call it
what a wired the decoy loading - what do
you mean the decoy loading tube
what is that I don't know what that is
can you explain it to me good use
alrighty then I'm just gonna put these
in my mouth because I believe that still
works like I think it would okay so that
works I got food inside of me and the
new user interface is just down with a
damn cool okay but at least everybody's
still here Astro art hold on to this
[ __ ] because I'm gonna need to go on an
adventure here so I'm just gonna yeah
I'm gonna put these back in Jonas grab
which is where that should be but
everything seems to be good so I'm going
to go out and I'm going to see if I can
repair something that is that because
that's bizarre there's actually an
animation for that now boy howdy they're
putting some polish on this babble oh my
god maybe that's what the banging was
before let me put this over here
Oh click-and-drag interface I love it -
oh sweet digs bro I think I got the ion
battery in this bad boy
Oh damage let me repair you never mind
apparently aah laughs okay so now I
actually have to be careful with this
little [ __ ] I know foreign concept for
everybody out there but uh you know I'm
gonna just try to try a little bit
that's right very hard obviously I don't
want actually put in the effort to what
I do in this but I'm gonna try just a
little bit oh look hello - indicator
that I'm going to ignore and then drown
all the time system from concrete can't
come what what did you just say
cavitating excessive noise did you just
purge the ghosts holy [ __ ] he's just
ghost busted that's [ __ ] oh my god the
whole thing listed to decide and then we
are no more ghosts
[ __ ] alright then Tom I knew I'm gonna
take this out of there and I'm gonna
charge it up because apparently we're
taking a bit of power here let's see so
your normal Power Cells but I thought I
had or yeah you know what that's okay
I'm gonna just how about trade out
because I can oh it looks so pretty it
do it looks so pretty like no joke it
looks real pretty the only thing I don't
have is a full readout of how much power
might my thing adds it's not the top
anymore unless that green bar is it or
less of some sort of objective weight
thing but either way we got oodles of
power so I'm not exactly worried about
that but last we go and apparently
that's a sonar navigating system which
any self-respecting submarine would have
that does not change our objectives
accepted changes exactly our objective
so I'm going to go over to the Mongolian
emissary and oh well there's my power
meter
well Baird oh I think my emergency
we can go faster Simon from my god that
is so cool if we go silent running does
that mean we're not gonna disturb any of
the people out there all torpedoes or is
that the decoy I love it I love this
okay here we go we're gonna cavitate and
cause some noise but we are [ __ ] it
baby I don't know if we're going any
faster than we have in the past but we
are [ __ ] bull okay net emergency
speed emergency speed yeah you're
goddamn right emergency speed but we got
an assload of power in our back so we
don't even need to worry about that so
that must be the noise so what if I oh
oh oh
Wong oh [ __ ] that's so cool that's so
cool what is that Oh Oh Charlie I don't
know what cavitating means but I'm
assuming that's bad also that radar
screen is awesome it reminds me of the
game homeworld the arena is a map yield
homeworld and homeworld do I would just
zoom out and you'd see like the the 3d
representation of the map and navigation
points that it would have there in okay
good to know that you're still doing
backflips but apparently it seems to be
loading a bit smoother than it has in
the past oh man I wonder what new
secrets are available in the dev build
oh the experimental version is so cool
why did I ever leave why did I go back
to release why did I oh that's right
because my same broken and like I
literally couldn't open my save anymore
but now I'm back oh I am back baby and
you are just freaking weird oh hi big
mushroom tree mama in a few low frames
here but at least you're looking good
and that
so I'm gonna hit these gonna eat eat eat
ah [ __ ] now did I did I do dabble its
zai do some tablets probably do wait
what did we miss jokey Oh rarely we miss
jokey kiss our let's circle back oh I
see it now I think I see Ruth what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] is attacking me what
the [ __ ] was that what what the [ __ ] was
that
oh something's hanging around our ass
and it does not like me oh it's coming
ah [ __ ]
what is attacking me but that schmuck
well jeez that's no good we're not doing
a lot of damage though so I'm assuming
it's not like a Leviathan or anything
like that
is it goddammit stop hitting me I'm
gonna slap you who's slapping me huh oh
it's just you you little shark bastard
why don't you take it up with well not
me because I don't want to fight your PO
I don't you take it on someone your own
size big box Barry is a gentle giant
just being a bully weevil to load he's a
bother
oh hi hello life pot of jokey kazar are
you doing what is this what is that open
data box whoa why I don't know what that
is what is that what is that jokey are
you doing bubble okay I got a voice log
what is that what is that what is that
oh that's the new lithium how am I gonna
be able to know what anything is anymore
Oh everything is garbo now oh no
everything's changed
oh absolutely everything has changed
oh my god
and I'm gonna need a few how many a few
minutes to wrap my head around all this
[ __ ] here we go let's listen to the
police longer hey what the [ __ ] was that
what the [ __ ] was that this is gonna be
[ __ ] with me this whole time huh geez
all right anyway whatever wait ah data
downloads lifepod here we go life table
systems online passenger oh seven
emissary Joe [ __ ] saw has boarded the
Life pod by pod launch sequence
initiated
life more detached for your order okay
onboard microphone recordings my
creators the Cherisher and sustainer zuv
world give me this day my daily goods
and allow me my pleasures as i allow
those who seek pleasures from me
well that's creepy and weird entering
planetary atmosphere external
temperature approaching critical levels
show me the path in life in truth and
love in substance principle in mind for
- the power I am the one for ever and
ever on and off and on again exterior
Hall damaged life poor systems failed
impact intimate life is game which is
universe plays with itself I'm done
pretending to merely be merely this
bundle of flesh I am ready to play for a
different side well he was doing his
death prayer I think pretty sure that's
what that was huh hear it so what was
the thing that I got from them because I
got something but what did it mean like
it said something about it modified my
crafting systems or something like that
god I really don't know that's super
weird I'm gonna have to you guys are
gonna have to tell me about that one
because I don't know what that wok it I
just pissed myself but I don't know what
that was so I got a fine man out later
but I will get to that in a little bit
how everything looks so shiny and new oh
I'm gonna drink this pale
okay then then I'm going to take some
more fruit and then I'm going to be good
to go
that is going to take forever to fill
that battery but alas we have plenty of
power with which to do that okay and
away we go
we need to rendezvous with bubble butt
and then make ourselves everything that
we need and apparently we're cavitating
and making too much noise which is going
to cause us to become tax cavitating
that's something like attractive a ting
or bringing towards us because
apparently nothing nothing likes noise
which means that suddenly we're in
danger again which is both a good and
bad thing because in any game that has
horror elements and this is definitely
one over you can't say it's not but in
any game where you remove the threats
and you give yourself a safe harbor like
this boat that was invincible it becomes
less threatening and therefore less
scary but now I'm in danger wherever I
go no matter what is out there it might
be able to kill me and I know that this
can now go a little bit faster but I
don't think that's enough to be able to
get away from say a Reaper love Ivan or
a sea dragon or anything of that sort
which means that when we approach such
monstrosity x' we're going to have to
creep as quietly it'll catch traffic and
try to avoid all the monsters aquitine
and I guarantee
in the experimental build there's going
to be monsters of epic proportions that
we cannot even come close to imagining
excuse me honk honk are you the monsters
of epic proportions of with which we
cannot possibly imagine
all right fly men have a lovely day
don't look at me like that you weird
weird monster I will not pay child
support get out of here with that bull
all right I'll meet you back at the base
oh I see bubble butt whoa
rocks Jesus no one warned me about that
I didn't get it oh there it is there's
the proximity warning Jesus all right go
on back to traffic I'm aware we're
cavitating I don't know why you got to
save having such a threatening Rumble oh
the old base what a lovely place
oh hey war pea whoo hopefully you're not
gonna be a dick to me okay
I got my own pool here how about you
stop being six deuce I got the outside
floodlights did they fix this and make
it any better maybe through the cameras
definitely would you think oh okay bye
then
warper bigger who ever looked a little
bit bigger to me okay so I got to go
trade these on the CMOS and replace the
place mr. Pfister in there because I'm
going to be taking the semen out and
about because the seamoth is so flippin
fast and I kind of want to see if
there's been any updates to the seamoth
hello
oh that's not good oh that's not good oh
that's not go now that's not good I
forgot that I didn't have a whole
modification in that so what I got to do
is that going to build one of those
before I do anything else all right what
do we plasteel and computer chip I can
do both of those things cuz I got all
the necessary materials is I need to
make an ingot about doing that power we
do have power here man those viola are
always serious here those bio reactors
have been make it Mickey what have they
been making power out of cuz it's been
ages since I filled you oh my god I
don't believe that for a moment I'm
sorry I just don't believe that I just
do not believe that you have power here
because that is a goddamn ridiculous you
there's no way that you have power that
is a load of [ __ ] okay but either
way I got my plasteel ingot and
thankfully I don't need to go any deeper
than just this so I've got what you
might call it I'm making a blast dealing
it so we got a plasteel again we need a
computer chip I believe all my silver is
back in my my Cyclops I'm gonna go for
that smoosh okay well right even got
this loopy will it's just not all
systems are in line thank you again
why does it every time I get in this
thing it pushed me back why there's some
wonky physics going on here but then
again it is experimental mode so I guess
that's to be expected
all right so I need I need to make a
computer chip you got it buddy boo I
know where to do that I've got silver in
here and then I've got coral coral
where's the goddamn coral coral no coral
table coral yeah table coral that's it
and God all these new icons I have no
idea what they are but at least they're
more distinct like
that is something that I can't applaud
about it it is definitely distinct now
all right so I need to make a computer
chip Oh what gold gold did they change
that they changed that didn't they gold
well good maybe that's going to be less
silver required because silver was
overused and gold was not used you're
telling me that [ __ ] ain't gold gold
gold gold there it is and then what else
what else did you need copper wires we
need copper okay
copper copper copper copper wire which
makes sense I don't even think it needed
copper wire before but it didn't seem to
do that for the computer chips but now
computer chip kind of makes a little bit
more sense because usually for
electronics when you're connecting
things it's usually gold but to go to be
used for that so when they didn't have
gold available then I was a little bit
confused did we list again every time I
go up to those ladders like that
particular ladder there every time I go
up it I am a mile away from my base in
the open ocean it's goddamn terrifying
out here don't do that to me son of a
biscuit here we go bubble bumble bud all
right so we're gonna make this the
pressure compensator because we never
run god just flashing lights no joke
alright put you in this bad boy here off
and point crushed steps is now 300
meters barely what I need but it's
enough to get by so I'm gonna I guess
I'm gonna take that it is cuckoo duty to
do it okay hi why did you do that mister
warper who missed me by a hair missed me
by the hair on my chinny chin you're too
fast for me whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa I don't like that at all
so you can go F yourself mr. Warner who
is now much more aggressive about his
job which I would expect the warper is
there to conceal
what what did I do what hurt me what is
that what are you talking about I'm
gonna Ram you if you're gonna be a son
of a [ __ ] I'm gonna Ram the [ __ ] out of
you get rekt I am oh [ __ ] you dude
but that kills you that it did I didn't
I did a number on my my guy here but
he's doing okay he's doing all right so
I'm gonna go out a number repair that
real quick and then I'm gonna move on
because it seems like things are giving
me some agita so if I can fix the
goddamn leaks which are all no oh man
this makes it a lot more stressful makes
a lot more problematic oh [ __ ] yeah
Jesus okay look at that
okay goddamn what are they doing to my
boat bubble-butt big bucks Barry they're
doing everything to you guys okay I got
to get in and I got to get my gotta get
mr. Pfister into the upgrade chamber
because I need to upgrade that nice
[ __ ] kind of go get eggs I haven't
even done that I haven't even made my
god stop that stop that Oh fine I just
need to stop going up that elevator now
okay here we go sploosh oh use the Jets
okay fire okay we're almost there whoa
whoa whoa whoa
holy [ __ ] oh this is hard to control huh
there we go okay nailed it in there just
by the hair on our chinny Chinchin
why is this underwater now what the [ __ ]
did you do
what what happened what happened to my
base what did you [ __ ] do what do
you do
what you'd do to my face ah
Fricke dick seems like it's out of power
suddenly oh geez okay so I need the
prawn suit jet upgrade which means I
need kyanite sulfur and plasteel which I
think I can do and I think I have if I
remember how to make kyanite which I
believe is that material I believe it's
not something to be made I believe it's
just that material that's in one of my
storage units because I have sulfur and
I have the materials to be able to make
plasteel the man this is kitten that is
getting regard damn thick Gillis
oh wait that's it that that's not
kyanite it is okay so I have the kyanite
I have exactly three which is who
thankful oh there was more in here okay
good okay but I'm gonna leave it in
there for now and now I'm gonna make
another plasteel ingot when do okay then
I need lithium right Roy Roy right right
there okay man this is this weird I like
it
I like new I like new I got a I'm in I
like change
I do like chains some people don't like
change me me I'm like changing a lot la
la la
okay so we got the class steel then we
just need to make these no we just need
to take the sulfur over there and we're
good to go
we're good to go then we're gonna get a
jet afraid on this bad boy and that's
gonna be the first step onto the new me
the whole new world that is me for some
reason this is still under water and I
don't know it's even higher under what
what happened here what is happening why
are you drowning
why are you drowning this makes no sense
what is happening to you I don't
understand but I got this is something
is happening here why it's just getting
further and further under water
this isn't right something's going on
here
I don't even know I don't even know man
what are the only two whoa
I thought that was my shadow I thought
it was a creature the only thing I know
that I oh my god
when did this happen what did this
happen when the [ __ ] did that happen
they out of there Gordon the other
goddamn Island training sister
conditional oh I didn't even know there
was gonna be damage
I didn't even understand where that
happened well are the draining systems
active or are they not because it seems
to be not drained seasons you have any
Christmas a good good thing that all of
my uh all of my devices are waterproof
[ __ ] oh there was a sploosh give me some
oxygen here oh man that's so weird
it must have been one my big box Barry
like splooshed all over the place oh man
I need a coffee because this very exact
ulis what I can scan this I have it why
don't we just scan it alright here we go
I need to scan you before I use you my
ears can't hear at the same time there
we go coffee americano blue okay well I
got that so that's good okay so I think
I'm gonna have to end this episode here
I did not get everything that I wanted
to get because all of this new stuff
just punched me right in the face but
I'm gonna roll with the punches and I'm
going to keep going with this so thank
you everybody so much for watching
everything that's in these new
experimental builds bear with me and
help me out write in the comments what
I'm supposed to do and where I'm
supposed to go because these new things
are going to be rolling at us every day
now and we'll see what happens so thank
you everybody so much for watching as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
[Music]